thanks for coming and as we found out
this is I'm going to define the exact
same set of polynomials that that Judas
talked about and coming from a somewhat
so one of the nice things I think about
this whole sort of story is that it has
been approached in a lot of different
ways for a lot of different reasons and
the the same sort of set of polynomials
has the same sort of objects have come
out out of all of them and so let's
let's talk about those so just to repeat
things if I have a polynomial
long- coefficients and I say it's log
concave log concave
black one well this blue can read his
blue readable
polynomial non-negative coefficients say
it's log concave
on the positive orphans if as a function
from the positive orphan to our it's
concave at the log of it is concave if
so we should have so f is automatically
non negative it's positive on the
positive or 'then if it's a nonzero
polynomial and so they want log of that
function from the positive
and I'm just going to include because
it's a little bit easier to do I'm gonna
call the zero polynomial even though we
should not take the log of it and then
we're gonna say that F is completely
logged concave
if not only does eff have this property
but whenever you take any directional
derivatives in positive directions you
get a polynomial with this product
[Music]
tell your vectors for any non-negative
vectors
and here what I mean by this
differential operator is exactly this
time they use the same notation for
differentiation with respect to a
variable what I'm gonna do is I'm going
to pick a vector here my vector is going
to be non-negative and I'm just gonna
take the directional derivative in that
I said so this is this is the property
that I explore and offer you we just saw
sort of many examples but a priori you
know it's not clear that any polynomial
sort of fall into this category but a
very sort of quick example is if you
take a univariate real polynomial
[Music]
you know very good roots non-positive so
RI non-negative and then then there's
not so many choices for direct there's
only one direction to go in so we don't
have to worry about any of this
direction nonsense and if we try and
test whether or not it's logged concave
we take log is a not even multivariable
to single variable calculus problem let
me take the second derivative of log and
what we get so log of a product of the
sum
some of one over all of these things you
take the derivative again and what you
get is minus one which is going to be
negative for every real number that I
plug in so that means that the log is
concave
[Music]
one of the the big motivations for this
story I think from from our perspective
at least is a multivariable
generalization of real rootedness called
stability which we've already heard a
lot about during this week but so
another big example is polynomials
stable with non-negative coefficients
we're one definition of stability just
in case anyone hasn't seen it is that if
I take any univariate restriction I want
this to be real rooted whenever I walk
in a positive direction so when it for
all vectors the direction and I can
start from any point
the picture for this you draw the zero
set of a stable polynomial in two
variables and if it has degree 3
a set of set of points where this
polynomial is 0 and if I take any
restriction any line in the positive
direction I will find three real roots
of this polynomial
and sorta for the same reason such
polynomials are the log is is concave on
the non negative and it's interesting
because these were studied to sort of
first by also the very related class of
font on the hyperbolic phone emos were
studied by guarding for PDEs
and he actually showed that the the log
is is concave on it has sort of a
interesting history that way and so
these are log concave and if you take
any derivative just like if you take any
derivative of a real rooted polynomial
you get a real rooted polynomial and so
the same argument will go through if you
take any any multivariate polynomial and
you take one of these directional
derivatives just sort of like taking
which is the the same as taking the
derivative with respect to T of this
polynomial then you get you get another
stable polynomial and in fact the zero
set will interlace
so here okay
see Rosa
and so putting those two facts together
shows that any stable polynomial sort of
satisfies this property
[Applause]
and the thing I want to start off with
is a part of this long list of
equivalent conditions it was just
written down you have a homogeneous
polynomial
right down the same same list and add a
few things the first is that F is
completely logged concave
the other you know so we can go down the
list of things that laugh is strongly
logged concave which we saw a definition
of June stalker
Corinthian
razaw definition of gene stock and
there's a few other that I want to add
to this list one is that so as we as we
saw sort of here the thing that's
important is quadratics like that's
that's sort of where all the action is
happening and that's true even if you
allow yourself vectors in in any
directions so it's not too hard to check
that if you're taking directional
derivatives the ones that really matter
or when you take when you take as many
as you can
so this
and then the last one is sort of a
two-part condition which is I think an
analogous to this sort of M convex
analogous to the two-part condition we
saw before but I'm going to write down
slightly differently which is that one
whenever you take direct derivatives
really in the coordinate directions
whenever you take
exactly D minus two derivatives this is
exactly the same the same condition we
saw before and then the other that I
want to write down is that this is
whenever you take a directional
derivative you get something I'm gonna
call in decomposable
less than or equal to
where the thing that I want to we're in
decomposable is avoiding this this this
type of polynomial we saw before where
it's really a sum of polynomials in two
different sets of variables that's
trouble so we want to avoid those
any questions before I start erasing
anything
by the way from the terminology dip
world is already occupied in
decomposable for the product hopefully
no no no sir if you have a better word I
you know from Markov chains the natural
word is irreducible but I refuse to
change the definition of irreducible for
a polynomial the definition was used I
say well if you have a okay open to
changing open to changing so this is
really just F is not equal the sum of
two variables two polynomials nonzero
polynomials where G is in one set of
coordinates
[Music]
that's what I want to update for this
talk I'm going to call them daily
decomposable
other other questions
so I want to go through a few
interesting cases and and the first just
like we saw earlier today is is to think
about quadratics
if I have some some polynomial
in n variables quadratic I can write a
real symmetric matrix I mean we'll put a
half
and then if I if I do the natural thing
which is to take the Hessian of a law of
event
if you actually do it out this is the
multivariable calculus
exercise this is is the rank one matrix
we get from taking outer products of the
gradient and then you divide by an F
squared maybe I'll put an F squared over
here
in this matrix this is a matrix this is
really cute
take a quadratic polynomial we take the
Hessian we just get you're representing
matrix and the way that I would and so
this has to be negative semi definite
when we evaluate at any point in the non
negative court
[Music]
and of course Q doesn't so what depends
on the evaluating at a point F changes
as you f varies with the point this is
just a constant matrix and this changes
a bit but the the way that I think it's
best to read this is that we have a
quadratic form and when we were
subtracting off a rank one matrix form
with non-negative entries and we're
subtracting off a rank one matrix to
make it negative semidefinite back this
function
is negative semidefinite on the
orthogonal complement
whatever this vector
if we evaluate it at such a point where
this doesn't matter we need to get
something negative
and in the picture that I want to have
in mind for this is so this is
polynomial because the entries because
the entries of this are not negative it
necessarily is going to take positive
values on the positive on the nine
negative orphaned and what this
condition says is that there's some some
linear space on which it's negative and
negative semi done positive
and so then in between it really should
be zero
this is not a great picture because
and so what really has to happen is that
this quadratic polynomial has to be
stable from doing homogeneous the honest
picture here is really two straight
lines
the 3d picture which is harder to draw
arrow set of
negative semidefinite ensemble in years
little queue is that
and so we said before that every stable
polynomial has this property and for
homogeneous quadratics it's really the
same
and it's not the same in general as a
spoiler or Aquatics it's really the same
thing
a tiny example if we had a bivariate
quadratic variables a 2x squared
this is completely logged concave if and
only if the Hessian
one has determinant less than equal to
zero
justbe which will give us the usual sort
of discriminant for a degree to ponder
and if we if we jump down to to this
then we recover something that I think
was also in Leonids paper which was that
if you have a polynomial of degree n
then this this polynomial has this
property if and only if so let's write
down this condition really just
translate to support the fact that the
support set of case where a K is not a
zero is an interval there's no gaps
and all of the things you can you can
get by taking derivatives of this down
to a quadratic gives you a quadratic of
this form determinant all of the
Hessians so I can take the derivative
with respect to X sometimes and the
derivative with respect to Y sometimes
is non-negative every sort of triple of
consecutive coefficients I mean it get
some inequality and as we saw this is
these inequalities are really nice wish
translates to exactly these inequalities
that the coefficients are ultra log
concave so this is that you can homework
is that if you take all of these if you
take derivatives to get down to a
quadratic and you take the determinant
by two matrix you get a bunch of
inequality
and so here you know we really see
already there's a difference between
sort of real stables so this polynomial
is stable if and only if sort of the
univariate polynomial is real rooted
real if they're real polynomial you get
by restricting why de 1 is real Brigitte
that's the condition for stability which
implies these inequalities on the
coefficients but is not equivalent to
these inequalities so we're really get
something something stronger
[Music]
so the pair so these you should go
together you need to you need both
people to see it one statement since
that operating was Newton inequalities
right the ratios are monotonically
decrease no corresponding gursha
then then it immediately with employees
actually go away okay well I mean I also
I like this both because it you know as
an illustration what would happen if it
was not consecutive if there was a gap
then you take derivatives to isolate the
left side of the gap and the right side
of the gap and you're gonna get
something looks like X to the something
and then why did there's something with
nothing in between and that you can
write as a sum of polynomials in
separate variables
I'm gonna talk
[Music]
I want to basically just I'm not gonna
sketch uh proof of any of these things
but I want to just talk about sort of
one or two pieces that I find nice that
are involved in this and that people who
care about you know stable polynomials
and interlacing families might
and one is one question you could ask
about such polynomials as when can you
add them and preserve this property
again so a lot of this is sort of
inspired by the theory of stable
economies which we've heard a lot about
heard about a lot about this week and if
you have two stable polynomials or two
real rooted polynomials and you want to
add them and get something real routed
out then it's it's very convenient to
have a common interlace ER to be able to
sort of separate the roots of these
polynomials into intervals I think it'd
be very interesting to develop an
analogue of this story for for these
polynomials and the closest that here's
a here's a baby step towards towards
doing that is suppose you have two
polynomials
of the same degree and they have a
common derivative
[Music]
zero
I'm vectors V W
some non-negative vectors in W then I
claim concave and they have a common
derivative then I claim the sum is
and the idea is really that when you get
down when you get down to taking
derivatives and getting down to
quadratics they're going to have a
common interlace
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
namely me of this and GW of
and so really you have to two quadratics
they're both none they're both positive
on the positive or --then they're both
negative on some linear space and so
when you add them together those
properties are preserved
I mean you know you have to make some
are you meant to say if you know it for
quadratics and you know it for
everything but and so the question we
saw all this stuff about interlacing
phat well you know there's all this
useful stuff for stable polynomials and
the question for all if for pretty much
everything I write down is like what is
there an analogue for every you know
theorem about stable polynomials you
want to ask like there's some good
analogy for this there's lots of people
this semester I think trying to
understand what the set of inter lasers
are of these polynomials would be a very
interesting
so yeah is still puzzled by this
consideration if you look at vectors
orthogonal to the gradient of that point
X will be you know Farmington for any
form of Q's we can get at this transpose
G of X but there is another X transpose
QX coming out the pound so how would you
actually get to let's do it actually cuz
it's also inside it seems to square your
what you want
okay so f there's gonna be constants
that might go wrong but let's so so
asses so I'm gonna evaluate at some
point passion and then this is like
that's my matrix and I want this to be
I'm gonna ignore this for a moment
that's okay there's constants they don't
end up mattering okay but let's
let's to be negative for all choices of
be right and and one sort of I really
like is this is actually the determinant
is always to be negative and this is
really what is this doing to Q this is
restricting it a two dimensional linear
space
that's this matrix
and and so this as I restrict to the
quadratic form q2 any two-dimensional
linear space it's still gonna have this
is non-negative or this is really
positive this is some positive number so
the matrix is not going to be negative
there's gonna be at least one positive
eigenvalue and this is saying that
there's that's there's also a negative
eigenvalue or not you know
and so this is saying for every you take
some vector in the positive direction
you take any other vector and you
restrict to this linear space you get an
indefinite
and we can really translate that this is
if and only if Q
let me definite
on a linear space of
then when you ever take whenever you
take a two dimensional linear space
you're going to intersect this and
you're going to get a negative
well is your your original question
again we'll go
okay
it is possible it seems weird because
you have this matrix with non-negative
entries and many of its eigenvalues are
negative all but one in its eigenvalues
non-negative entries
[Music]
other questions
and so what does
[Music]
what this means is it lets you sort of
move around move around the the vectors
in these derivatives and in particular
you can sort of deform these vectors to
the unit vectors in order to get really
the derivatives with respect to the
variable
I'm sorry is this how you prove the
Goodwin's right so it's basically the
the main moving part is that idea right
yeah yeah it's really just get it down
to quadratic form you get down to sort
of the quadratic case and then you can
move move these around and that there's
in decomposable so this the other claim
is but is it derivatives that are
completely law concave well I and
as this property then f is
that prove it
all right national derivatives are
clearly law concave
and again the idea is that derivatives
have
a common natural common danger laser
namely you take the derivative with
respect to both of them so long as so
long as this is is nonzero this is going
to allow you to take sort of
non-negative combinations of
but it and so long sort of laundry list
of all these things but all of the
arguments are really what happens to
quadratic forms and then like basic
computations on polynomials
okay
and one of the one of the things that
are very nice about these polynomials or
maybe I'll start with one of the things
that always sort of bugged me about
stable polynomial polynomials are
beautiful we love them there is this
there's this nice theorem
Waggener that if you have a multi a fine
with non-native coefficients if this is
stable
than the support
some subsets for which this coefficient
is not equal to zero that this these are
the basis of some a trade
but I like a lot and you can ask a
natural question is well it's for an
example you know the elementary
symmetric polynomials are beautiful up
to a constant by taking the directional
derivative just the product of the
variables beautiful stay Lovano meal and
what I mean by support is I take where I
take well 1 X 1 X 2 shows up with
nonzero coefficient X 1 X 3 shows up
with nonzero coefficient X 2 X 3 shows
up with nonzero coefficient and the
corresponding mate right is the uniform
metroid' of rank two and three elements
so there's also this sort of
combinatorial structure showing up in
stable polynomials but not all major oh
it's come this way
so Peter Brendan
shut that sorry not all made roads
explicitly the Fano metroid is not the
support of any stable and there's many
others and it's a little bit of a mess
like which ones show up and which one
doesn't I always find this a little bit
sad
I like sable polynomials and I like
Metroid's and you know you'd want them
to have a tighter connection so for me
one of the big selling points of of this
generalization is that it really
captures meat or illness which is
exactly what
as one of the theorems that that he
wrote down for more general job systems
as if you have any may trade
then the basis generating polynomial is
completely law concave
all the babies
yes if this is completely a lot of
complicated
and so this really captures so not only
is is the analog of this statement true
if you have any coefficients that make
your polynomial completely log concave
or lawrencium then its support or the
basis of some some major ID but you can
take the coefficients all to be one
and so this is one of the nice sort of
polynomials on the boundary that we saw
on this okay
and if you want to for example get any
quality is on the in the number of
independent sets of a major I'd it's
nice to notice some over all of the sets
modernization of the independence at
polynomial
this is also
which you can check and you can check by
using sort of these to either the I mean
any one of these things right this and
some of them are easier than others
I think this one is one can check and
it's sort of the same calculation is
checking that that these are so what do
you do is you can indeed composability
maybe it corresponds to sound the
support of metroid polynomials and then
log concavity you can check by really
just taking derivatives to get to a
quadratic
another fun sort of homework exercise is
to take polynomials like this and see
what differentiation let's see what
differentiation does in terms of the
corresponding major
and and one of the one piece of this
story is that for real stable
polynomials as we have seen throughout
the week if you have a stable polynomial
you can think of it as a probability
measure given by the coefficients and
then you can you know go to town I'm
using approximation algorithms for that
using that probability distribution and
so my co-authors Neema and Cheyenne have
been doing this with a lot of stable you
know doing this for stable of
polynomials and they had the same sort
of frustration that you know we want to
talk about allmate roids but it's
difficult to get a handle on all Metroid
's and so one of the pieces of this
puzzle is that we sort of been all of
the stuff that works for stable
polynomials we've been trying to do
expanded to this
so explicitly to talk about probability
distributions some probability
distribution on subsets of 1 through n
I could write down it's it's generating
polynomial which will be
nice multi a fine polynomial whose
coefficients from the probabilities
if there if this is an honest
probability distribution note that when
I plug in the all ones vector I get one
starting up over the probabilities of
all those cents and then
so we've seen a lot this week
strongly Rayleigh distributions
which are really adjusts distributions
so that this generating polynomial
and so the analogous thing to do is is
to put down the condition that this
generating polynomial is
lazy with our terminology we could just
say it
do you homogenized this I do not
although most of the examples we've
considered have been homogeneous
actually you could also so this
definition that I wrote down of complete
law concavity didn't require homogeneity
you could also do it for non homogeneity
in homogeneous polynomials and one of
the things that seems to be true is if
you have a in homogeneous polynomial
with this property complete log
concavity then you can sort of
homogenized it in a scaled way and get a
homogeneous one some polynomial and you
write it as as a sum of it sort of if
you have some polynomial then
that is completely logged concave if and
only if I sort of
weird how modernization
so there's also sort of an in a
non-homogenous version of all of this
stuff we haven't found I don't think we
have any good applications of it but it
sort of out there and would be
interesting to understand that yeah so
aa priori it doesn't need to be
supported on only set so size
[Music]
and so
so one thing that one might want to do
given given access to a such a
distribution is to sample from it for
example we might want to pick bases from
a mate roid or count the number of bases
of a mate Road and one of the things
that Nima and Cheyenne sort of had built
up is that for many probably many people
in the room had built up is that for
strongly Rayleigh measures you can do
all of these things effectively you can
do good sort of approximations to these
measures and two counts of their
supports and they're nice to work with
and so part of the thing we try to build
up is to do the same thing for these
measures
it gives a super short version of what I
was going to say
it's a super short and bad version of
what I was going to say is that
[Music]
approximate for example the size of the
support
of such a matter well using a convex
program
[Music]
this is our the the number of subsets
such that new of us is not equal to zero
for example if you took the uniform
distribution over the basis of a mate
right this would just give you the
number of phases and what what creepy
we'll talk about tomorrow is that you
can also sort of define a Markov chain
the support of these things that mixes
quickly come back come back tomorrow
morning for babies talk and in the few
minutes remaining
have everyone everyone in the room
I wanted to just sort of present a
question to the crowd which was that all
of this sort of started for for me at
least this all started by by Singh Joon
talk about hodge riemann relations on
things and translating it into things
about polynomials so sort of a fancy way
of writing down the definition of
complete log concavity a certain poetic
form
Lauren Darr which eats a vector
it's at the following number
you pick some vectors v1 through the G
minus 1 this is a different operator of
degree D this is a polynomial
homogeneous of degree D this will spit
out a number this is negative semi
definite the kernel is a linear map
namely the one that eats W and spits out
where
for all all choices vectors
convince yourself that this is a linear
space this is a quadratic form that's
the that's the sort of statement and if
you okay modulo sort of replacing
negative semidefinite was negative
definite this is the mixed ha dreamin
relations at sort of the first level
there's a lot of them and this is level
one and I think a lot of nice things
sort of came out of level one and it
would be really cool to try and one of
the things that I was sort of curious
about and have no ins are to is what the
higher ones look like so
we might instead consider the condition
that the quadratic form
that eats polynomial differential
operator
how many uses 3q spits out a real number
that comes in intuition for these I
encourage you to ask June and Kareem
more in LA
that this is
on the colonel lives on map
all vectors vectors in the non-negative
Ortolan hope this is an adequate
translation that's the higher higher
degree ones and as far as I know if this
property is is not terribly this class
of polynomial satisfying this is is not
I don't think it's even known if stable
polynomial sort of fall into it satisfy
this yeah so so I tried that
okay so no so the problem from geometric
point of views I mean it's not so simple
so that you know that for that
formulation to work the variety that you
have secretly in your mind it has to be
sort of a smooth and the reason why that
property fails for stable polynomials is
that the top indicates the ring that's
behind your polynomial F yeah it's not
the ring that satisfies the hot
regulation so in this formulation the
Palmolive ring you have separately in
mind this like polynomial ring modulo
the Annihilator yeah that's not the
right ring that's not the right ring oh
no you're a sort of a forcing Frank
hydrology but the ring you actually want
is not that one and actually it's a fun
exercise to come up with a counter
example to that statement for stable
polynomials harder exercise great is
there a right ring there should exist
the right range but it's not as
okay yeah so I was thinking a little bit
about what the buzz is definition and
it's Kinnock so what you do here in this
table you can get with difference length
n minus two times and you get to a step
over the nominal or degrade to I what
about your different shape n minus 3
times and you get to step up a little um
a low degree that may be more okay
and the reason this why I was thinking
about them it's actually so my interest
all the stuff was proving over bones and
the coefficients was one department and
actually there is a big difference
between state walk you get different
constants there so but if you if you
that level gives us if you get stability
you get better constants so this would
be the definition that's a question that
makes sense
so I could be like hey Caleb okay so
just getting to the Sun different [ __ ] n
minus K times you give you know case
that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you again how can bring a new song
with it 11 put it back